What makes a bonus so dangerous?
How can a virus overwhelmed?
They're very complex defense system of
the body so quickly and so effectively.
Let's take a look at what Ebola does.
Ebola is a virus.
A virus is a very small thing,
a bit of RNA or DNA and
a few proteins in a hole.
It has no ability to do anything by
itself whatsoever and can only survive and
proliferate by infecting cells. To
avoid this, we have the immune system.
The immune system is super complex,
so we developed a visual system
that makes it easy to understand.
So it looks like this.
Let's concentrate on the part that's
critical to understanding of Bola and
ignore the rest.
So usually dendritic cells would
activate an army of antivirus cells,
support cells and antibody factories
that work together with the guard cells
wipe out the infection and a matter
of days. But when Ebola strikes,
it directly attacks the immune system.
Some of the first sales it takes over our,
the dendritic cells,
the brains of the immune system,
the Ebola virus,
and is a dendritic cell by binding
onto receptors for cell transport.
Once it's insight,
it dissolves it's outer hole and
releases its genetic material,
nuclear proteins and enzymes. In a
nutshell, it takes over the cell,
disables the cells,
protective mechanisms and reprograms
at the cell now becomes a fire risk
reduction machine and uses its
resources to build Ebola virus hits.
Once the cell is saturated,
it dissolves the cell membrane and
millions of viruses are released into the
tissue.
The virus not only prevents the dendritic
cell from activating the specialized
antivirus forces,
it manipulates it into sending signal
proteins that trick the specialized cells
into ending their own lives prematurely,
so the immune system is
seriously disrupted and unable
to react while the virus
rapidly multiplies.
We're talking billions.
There are cells that should deal with
infected cells, the natural killer cells,
but they also get infected and just die
before they can prevent the disease from
spreading. At the same time, a bowler
infects the guard cells of the body,
macrophages and monocytes not only
managing to circumvent their defenses,
it also manipulates them to signal to
the cells that make up the blood vessels,
telling them to release fluids into
the body. Usually there's makes sense,
but in this case it just causes mayhem
all over the body and neutrophils are
activated a welcome by the virus
and the macrophages signals.
They're not very effective against
viruses and should not be involved in this
fight and begin to do lots
of stuff they shouldn't do.
The neutrophils signal the blood vessels
to release more fluid causing internal
bleeding. Another area of the body
of bone or attacks is the liver.
The virus,
it very easy to enter the liver and it
quickly starts killing loads of liver
cells and causing organ failure and
more internal bleeding and all of those
things are going on at the
same time as the virus spreads.
It's like nukes exploding everywhere.
One incident of this in one
region would be problem enough,
but now it's starting to happen
everywhere at once. All the mechanisms,
the immune system has evolved to handle
infections work against you and the
virus continues to spread and spread and
finally begins to infect more and more
body cells while the body
desperately struggles to stay alive.
In a desperate last
effort to turn the tide.
The immune system
launches a cytokine storm.
A cytokine storm is an SOS signal that
causes the immune system to launch all of
its weapons all at once in
a desperate kamikaze attack.
This hurts the virus, but leaves
behind tons of collateral damage,
especially in the blood vessels.
Paradoxically,
the healthier the immune system,
the more damage it can do to itself.
More and more off to it
leaves the bloodstream.
Blood pours out of every opening of the
body. You become seriously dehydrated.
There's just not enough blood left to
supply the organs with oxygen and cells
begin to die. If you reach this point,
the chance of you dying is very high.
Currently, six out of 10 in
fact, it's die from Ebola. Wow.
Okay. Ebola is nasty, so it's
time to panic, right? No,
not even close.
The severity of Ebola gets papers
sold and the youtube video shed,
so everybody is talking about Ebola,
but currently the only way to get infected
by a boater is to come into contact
with the bodily fluids of a person who
show symptoms or from an infected bat.
So just don't do that.
Ebola has killed 5,000 people since June,
2014 the common flu kills up
to 500,000 people each year.
Malaria kills up to 1 million each year,
3000 people every single day,
10 children since this video started.
So even if Ebola is terrible and scary,
don't let yourself be scared.
The most infectious thing about
Ebola is the media hype around it.
You could learn a bit more
about the immune system though.